I'm getting towards the end of my week
at the Riviera and I don't know if
looook is still speaking to me last
night he reacted badly when an A
inspector confirmed that his food was
over fussy what's the first thing you
thought about the small Inn after
yesterday we the inspector was the was
one message you you learned from it um
now I asked your advice
I had his advice as well so one you can
say maybe is wrong do stuff to take care
of us in and maybe I am wrong so it's a
different thing to accept the French
franc has finally dropped it's been hard
for living but he's already changing his
game plan he's come up with a new much
simpler idea at the Scala patient
it looks [ __ ] brilliant and why I can
identify now I know there's Apple
because you kept the green on there I
know there's rocket I know there's
pumpkin seed and it makes me feel
comfortable because I know what I'm
about to eat yeah I can identify what
you're doing that that's delicious
everything that goes on the plate has to
have a reason not for this but for here
yeah for the palette and what you've
just done there
looook you've given your food clear
insight okay it's not three four five
rosette for me I'd be happy eating that
anywhere you know that where's that
[ __ ] inspector she turn [ __ ] you now
hallelujah
I've just taken [ __ ] France now Louie
has finally swallowed his pride we can
begin to move forward with his team
behind him maybe he has a chance of
achieving his ultimate goal and he told
me that you wanted a mission his style
and at first I didn't think that was
possible you know that because of
how things got so complicated but with
this here there's no two ways about it
that's definitely worth the start
I respect lyric for taking it on board
but because it's [ __ ] hard lesson
very hard lesson but yeah it's got to
work hasn't it Mitchell first hatchet
job you can't afford to [ __ ] that
crucial you've got the right training
now you've got the perfect position to
do it